١٣ألف روسي
ماتوا في دونباس
هكذا جاء في تقرير الأمم المتحدة،
بوتين ينظر يمينا وشمالا
وما من أحد يتحدث عن هذا الخبر،
فشمر عن ساعديه وترك العالم يشاهده
وهو يأخذ الأراضي الأوكرانية
واحدة تلو أخرى،
ويقول للعالم أين كنتم عندما سقط مواطنونا؟
بوتين لا يخاف قادة الغرب
ولكنه يقبل بالتفاوض وفق شروطه
لإيقاف عملياته العسكرية في أوكرانيا،،
الرئيس الأوكراني في طريقه
للخضوع لطلبات موسكو،
وتركيا هي الوسيط هذه المرة،
وخلال ذلك تواصل قوات موسكو التقدم نحو كييف
، واتهام يوجه نحو أمريكا
بنشر الأمراض والأوبئة،
فهل هناك دليل على ذلك؟
عندما شاهد العالم قوة الدب الروسي
لم يملك الا التصريحات والتنديدات
إضافة إلى العقوبات الغربية
التي يعلمون أنها لن تجدي نفعا مع بوتين،
فروسيا لديها الكثير من البدائل،
فما هي تلك البدائل يا ترى؟
وماذا أنتم فاعلون أيها الغربيون؟
الغرب يتعاطف مع زيلينسكي وأوكرانيا
ويصفقون له بحرارة في كل جلساتهم
لكن لا أحد يلتفت إلى مطالبه...
فهل ينحني زيلينسكي للمفاوضات
بعد معرفته بخيانة الغرب له؟
وزير الخارجية التركي، مولود جاويش أوغلو،
عقب الإجتماع الثلاثي بين أوكرانيا وروسيا وتركيا،
قال "أننا طلبنا فتح ممر إنساني
في مدينة ماريوبول الأوكرانية،
ووافق الجانبان الروسي والأوكراني
على بحث الأمر مع المسؤولين في بلادهم"،
موضحاً "أننا حرصنا على إعطاء الأولوية
للبعد الإنساني ولذا نحتاج إلى وقف دائم لإطلاق النار"،
وتابع: "أكدنا ضرورة إبقاء الممرات الإنسانية
مفتوحة دون عائق".
ولفت أوغلو، إلى أن "أوكرانيا أكدت
استعداد رئيسها، فولوديمير زيلينسكي،
لعقد قمة ثلاثية في تركيا،
ولافروف، قال إن الرئيس الروسي، فلاديمير بوتين،
لا يعارضها مبدئيا"، موضحاً أن
"استمرار المحادثات بين الروس والأوكرانيين
يعتمد على مفاوضات بيلاروسيا".
قال وزير الخارجية  الروسي سيرجي لافروف،
إن بلاده  ذكّرت الأوكرانيين بأن موسكو
قدمت مقترحاتها بشأن الحوار وتنتظر ردًا،
مؤكدًا أن مد أوكرانيا بالسلاح من قبل الغرب
في غاية الخطورة وسيؤدي إلى تصعيد الصراع،
مشددًا على التزام بلاده بعدم مهاجمة أحد.
وأضاف لافروف، في مؤتمر صحفي عقده عقب لقائه
مع نظيره الأوكراني ديمتري كوليبا:
“لا نخطط للهجوم على أي دولة
ولم نهجم على أوكرانيا لكننا وصلنا
إلى وضع يشكل تهديدًا مباشرًا لأمننا”.
(الأحداث والتطورات)
...
زيلينسكي: لقد أغلقوا أكبر المدن وقطعوا الطعام والماء
عن المواطنين وقتلوا الأطفال..
الصين تعلن رفضها للعقوبات الأمريكية على روسيا..
ودعت الصين واشنطن إلى حمل مخاوفها
على محمل الجد ، فيما يخص الحرب في أوكرانيا
أو ما يخص علاقات الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
مع روسيا...
المستشار الألماني والرئيس الفرنسي
طالبا بوتين بضرورة إيجاد حل عبر التفاوض.
وزير الخارجية الأوكراني:
عرضنا على روسيا هدنة ل٢٤ ساعة
ولكن تم رفضها... ولم نحرز تقدما في ذلك...
العراق أولى الدول العربية التي أعلنت
وصول تداعيات الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية
إلى أراضيها، بارتفاع اسعار الدقيق والخبز
والشعب العراقي قلق من الوضع الحالي...
عقوبات أوروبية جديدة تستهدف سياسيين
ورجال أعمال مقربين من بوتين
(وتستهدف العقوبات التي فرضتها مفوضية الأمم الأوروبية:
١٤ من رجال الأعمال المقربين من الرئيس بوتين،
كما ستستهدف العقوبات أيضا
القطاع المصرفي والبنك المركزي في بيلاروسيا،
وزيرة الخارجية البريطانية:
لن نتخلى عما اتخذناه ضد موسكو،
وبوتين يجب أن يفشل
روسيا تتهم أمريكا بدعم ٣٠ معملا بيولوجيا
للأمراض الفتاكة في أوكرانيا،،
وتتضمن المعامل مسببات لأمراض الطاعون
والجمرة الخبيثة، وذلك بعد وثائق سرية
حصلت عليها موسكو إثر عملياتها العسكرية
في أوكرانيا.. (هذا الأمر نفته أوكرانيا
وأكد البنتاغون نفيه للموضوع أيضا
ولكن موسكو تطلب تفسيرا لما حدث
وتقول بأن لديها وثائق تثبت صحة أقوالها)
(لافروف: لا نمانع أي لقاء لحل المسائل
العالقة مع أوكرانيا)
قال المتحدث باسم وزارة الدفاع الروسية،
إيغور كوناشينكوف، إن 90 في المئة
من المطارات العسكرية الأوكرانية،
حيث كان يتمركز الجزء الرئيسي من الطيران العسكري،
توقفت عن العمل.
وأضاف، إن الجيش الروسي  قام بتدمير
146 طائرة مقاتلة ومروحية أوكرانية
من أصل 250، ونحو 2800
منشأة عسكرية أوكرانية .
وتقول أوكرانيا إنها قتلت آلاف العسكريين
الروس وأسقطت عشرات الطائرات في الحرب،
فيما تعلن روسيا حصيلة أقل كثيرا
مما تتحدث عنه كييف.
مكتب حقوق الإنسان التابع للأمم المتحدة:
توثيق مقتل وإصابة أكثر من ١٤٠٠مدني
منذ بدء الحرب في أوكرانيا...
ويعتقد المكتب أن العدد الحقيقي للضحايا
أعلى من ذلك بكثير ...
أمريكا تواصل رفضها إرسال طائرات مقاتلة
إلى أوكرانيا،، فهل يكون ذلك خوفا
من أن تكون في مواجهة مباشرة مع روسيا؟...
المعارك مستمرة في معظم الجبهات
لكن التركيز على العاصمة كييف
حيث يتمركز في شمالها الآلاف من القوات الروسية ..
صور لأرتال عسكرية روسية
تتجه نحو العاصمة الأوكرانية كييف..
وهذه صور أخرى لدخول القوات الروسية
مدينة سكادوفسك في خريسون
الكرملين يقول أن مزاعم أوكرانيا كاذبة فقط..
وأكد الكرملين: سنطلب معلومات من جيشنا
بشأن قصف مستشفى أوكراني في ماريوبول..
أردوغان: تركيا تتمسك بوحدة الأراضي الأوكرانية
واحترام سيادتها، ولقد دعوت بوتين وزيلنسكي
للحوار لأن منطقتنا لم تعد قادرة
على تحمل المزيد من تكاليف الحرب..
بعيدا عن النفط والغاز الروسيين
فهناك منتجات أخرى تصدرها روسيا للعالم
وتبقي الاقتصاد الروسي في مأمن
من غدر الدول الغربية...
الألومنيوم: تعتبر روسيا هي أسرع سوق
منتج للألومنيوم نمواً في العالم،
وسادس أكبر منتج ومصدر للألومنيوم في العالم
بقيمة تصديرية تجاوزت الـ .6060380. الف دولار.
الذهب هو ثامن أكبر منتج تصدير في روسيا
حيث بلغ إجمالي الصادرات 5,845 مليون دولار.
كشفت رئيسة مركز التصدير الروسي
فيرونيكا نيكيشينا عن تحول ملحوظ في تجارة روسيا
إن "صادرات روسيا غير السلعية (غير الطاقة)
بلغت في الفترة من يناير إلى نوفمبر الماضي
170.5 مليار دولار،
وعند النظر للعام الماضي بأكمله
فقد ارتفعت الصادرات بنسبة 36%
ووصلت إلى 191 مليار دولار،
وهي ذروة تاريخية جديدة".
ووفقا للخبيرة فقد تم تسجيل نمو في جميع قطاعات
المنتجات تقريبا، لكن النمو الأكبر
كان في المعادن الحديدية والأسمدة والكيماويات
والبلاستيك ومعدات الطاقة.
وعن أبرز مستوردي المنتجات الروسية
أظهرت البيانات أن الصين تصدرت القائمة
حيث استوردت منتجات من روسيا
بقيمة 15.6 مليار دولار،
ومن ثم كازاخستان (14.4 مليار دولار)،
وبعدها بيلاروسيا (11.4 مليار دولار)،
تليها تركيا (10.9 مليار دولار)،
ومن ثم الولايات المتحدة (7.9 مليار دولار).
الغرب يضغط على موسكو بعقوباتهم
وموسكو تثبت أنها ليست بحاجة لأحد
ولا تخاف أحد، فهل يصل بوتين إلى هدفه
بقواته العسكرية أم تخضع كييف بالتفاوض؟
...